le président du Conseil européen Charles
Michel promet de soutenir l'Ukraine dans
son adhésion à l'Union européenne
il s'agit d'un soutien à l'adhésion ou à
la demande d'adhésion
parce que Charles Michel il est obligé
de parler en tant que président d'une
instance qui représente les 27 pays de
l'Union européenne et comme souvent
évidemment ces 27 pays ils ne sont pas
tous d'accord sur le rythme auquel il
faut il faudrait accorder l'adhésion de
Kiev à l'Union européenne alors déjà il
faut rappeler que l'Ukraine a obtenu
très rapidement le statut de candidat et
maintenant il faut lancer officiellement
ces négociations vers l'adhésion des
négociations qui en général prennent
plusieurs années selon la situation du
pays candidat sur un certain nombre de
critères alors ça peut aller
relativement vite par exemple pour des
pays nordiques ça a pris quatre ou cinq
ans parce que que ce soit sur
l'indépendance de la justice à lutte
contre la corruption le respect de
l'État de droit
la liberté de la presse etc c'était des
pays qui étaient en bonne position en
revanche vous avez des pays comme les
pays balkaniques des Balkans par exemple
qui attendent depuis 2008 parce que
évidemment sur l'ensemble de ces
critères et bien ils ne sont pas encore
au niveau et puis il y a aussi des
critères un peu de fonctionnement de
l'économie pour que ces nouveaux pays
puissent commercer efficacement avec
l'Union européenne que ça profite à tout
le monde bon il y a enfin l'exemple
extrême de la Turquie qui est candidates
depuis 1999 et les négociations
européennes sont sont gelées depuis 2016
donc
au vu de ces de ces critères l'Ukraine
n'est pas très bien placé en termes de
respect de l'État droit de lutte
anticorruption voilà donc il y a des
pays européens qui disent oui mais vu la
situation à cause du conflit il faut
donner un signal politique fort et il
faut accélérer
cette demande d'adhésion c'est le cas
par exemple de la Pologne ou des pays
baltes et puis il y a d'autres pays
comme l'Allemagne et la France par
exemple qui disent faut pas trop se
presser il faut quand même que l'Ukraine
prenne le temps de bâtir un véritable
État de droit mène à bien salute
anticorruption et un développement de
son économie qui fasse que une adhésion
à l'Union européenne ne soit pas trop
dure pour elle-même voilà le débat et là
évidemment on a les représentants des
instants européennes qui doivent un peu
ménager la chèvre et le chou donc il
payait en guerre et puis le pays est en
guerre parle d'une adhésion d'ici deux
ans elle se réaliste alors les
Ukrainiens eux évidemment ils poussent
au maximum pour obtenir le lancement de
de ces négociations vers l'adhésion dès
aujourd'hui encore une fois ce n'est pas
gagné mais les Ukrainiens disent aux
Européens en gros aller au-delà de ces
histoires de critères etc justement
parce que nous sommes en guerre parce
que nous sommes agressés par un pays
autoritaire ce qui se joue au delà des
critères techniques à respecter c'est la
lutte entre un monde autoritaire incarné
par la Russie et le monde démocratique
et nous nous voulons faire partie de ce
monde démocratique et vous vous voulez
que nous en fassions partir comme
justement il y a un conflit il faut
adopter des positions un peu
exceptionnelles en fait des postures
exceptionnelles et donc il faut que vous
nous preniez très vite parce que ce qui
est menacé au-delà de notre liberté
c'est votre liberté à vous donc voyez
ils en font un combat un peu
civilisationnel pour convaincre l'Union
européenne d'accélérer c'est tout le
débat qui est posé on verra ce qu'il
ressort de ce sommet
Ukraine ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
l'Union européenne les 27 pays de
l'Union européenne sont quasiment tous
d'accord parce que même là il y a des il
y a quelques différences si on passe par
exemple à des pays comme comme la
Hongrie mais enfin ils sont quand même
globalement tous d'accord pour un
soutien sur le long terme à l'U dans ce
conflit une aide militaire qui a été
renforcée une aide financière qui
également a été renforcée là-dessus on
va dire il n'y a pas de problème après
le vrai point d'achoppement c'est est-ce
qu'il faut accélérer ce processus
d'adhésion à l'Union européenne les
réticences de certains des pays dont je
parlais notamment la France et
l'Allemagne c'est de dire ça va encore
plus crisper la Russie puisque justement
elle veut éviter que l'Ukraine tombe
dans l'escarcelle de l'OTAN et de
l'Union européenne si on va trop vite si
par exemple l'Ukraine était accepté dans
deux ou trois ans et bien évidemment
même pour l'ordre post conflit
évidemment ce sera très problématique
donc on se calme et il y en a d'autres
au contraire qui disent non il faut
accélérer merci beaucoup Bruno Darou
pour votre analyse merci à vous